the world's biggest problem is that
people don't believe themselves enough I
believe everybody has Michael Jordan
level Talent at something like you are
literally the world's greatest at
something but you either don't believe
that you are or you found the thing but
you don't believe in yourself enough to
actually go chase it down because it's
so different than what your family does
or your friends do or your community and
so whatever you think the world's
biggest problem is I think it's solvable
like if you say cancer I think the woman
who solves cancer should have already
solved it but instead she's a manager in
accounting company CU she never became a
doctor like I think that's the biggest
problem why do most people wake up and
drive to a job that they hate cuz they
don't they haven't tapped into the thing
that makes them joyous that allows them
to contribute and that's that's the
mission that I'm on for the rest of my
life hey it's EV Carmichael and I watch
these videos every day because I need
them for motivation being around
successful entrepreneurs every morning
helps me believe that I can do great
things too it's like your morning coffee
but for your goals kickstarting your day
with a blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
video every morning for the next 30 days
and let's find out together if they help
you do great things too if you're in
leave a # believe in the comments below
so I can celebrate with
you rule number two is stay consistent I
don't know that I've
done anything every single day with
intention with without fail um I mean
the to the spirit of the question I
thing I do the most consistently would
be injecting optimism into my life
whether it's a video whether it's a a
book whether it's um something that I
you know I I'm I'm reading on the
airplane or a film that I'm watch in a
documentary um injecting positivity is
probably consistently over the past 20
years the most consistent thing that
I've done now I'm very disciplined and I
have a lot of habits and most of my
habits I'm hitting 85 to 95% of the time
the health you know routine that we
talked about earlier you know but if I'm
traveling ing from here to Japan uh I'm
probably not hitting my sauna for the
day you know they're like just some
things that are not practical or it's
more detrimental to do it than not to do
it in some cases like it's better to go
and sleep than to go and do that thing
or it's better to serve because this is
a big opportunity than to go do that
thing so when it says you know do this
daily without fail I think the most
consistent thing is just injecting
optimism into my life and I'm okay with
hitting 85 to 90 % consistency on on my
habits as long as you're proud for me as
long as I'm proud of the reason why I'm
not doing it right so even making videos
the only time in the past decade plus
that I have not made videos I made
videos when I broke my neck I made
videos when I went on tour I made videos
through everything the only time I did
not make videos is when my uh dog died
my dog passed away on on uh video day
and I was just this family dog for you
know 13 14 years and uh I just I was
destroyed and I could not make videos
it's you are what you consistently do
not necessarily what you do every single
every single day rule number three is
know who you are who are you who is Evan
carmichel just a human trying to make an
impact you know like I think to
different people on different things oh
oh cool uh you know so like at that at
that event with Ed I was focused on
talking about YouTube strategies you
know to to you here we're talking about
buil to serve and purpose and introvert
right to other groups I'm I know I run
the largest salsa dancing school in
Canada it's har my wife in that group
they may not even know my videos or
books but I'm I'm the guy who owns the
salsa company um right to my son he
doesn't care about any of that stuff you
know he doesn't care about my book and
my I'm a dad yeah so I'm I'm different
things to different people happy to
dance with whatever energy they're
throwing out and um I'm just a human who
wants to make an impact rule number four
is consume information consciously being
in the industry so long watching so many
like if you think about what I do and
how many videos I watch of how many
successful people they all have some
core themes to them and whether it's
entrepreneurs or athletes or artist or
musicians or whoever they have similar
themes and and you know turning lemonade
or turning lemons into lemonade you know
turning a negative into a positive is is
a consistent theme across everybody and
so I think it just it happened
subconsciously just by being in the
environment of having those people
around me virtually to the point where I
was doing that exercise being forced to
sit with negative thoughts and it it I
had changed but I didn't notice like I
don't there was no moment of coming out
of the Cocoon and now I'm a butterfly it
just slowly became here I am as a
butterfly gotcha so it was just going
through the process yeah it's it's like
imagine if you were working out your
legs every day you don't you don't you
don't see a day-to-day difference right
there's no one moment like oh you did
one extra hard set and now you've got
these Rippling calves ready to go right
but I think the only difference was I
wasn't
even consciously training it was just
because it was in my environment and I
think that happens for a lot I think
that happens for most people just in a
negative way you're constantly watching
news and Twitter streams and all of this
negativity and all of a sudden you know
you start to become a negative person
because of all the things that are
happening around you but it's not that
you can pinpoint one thing that that was
the moment you became negative or even
notice that you're becoming negative
it's just happening and so that's the
power of when you shift your environment
and you're controlling what you're
consuming into your you know to your
brain so I was conscious what I was
consuming I wasn't conscious about a lot
of the transformation that happened as a
result it's only in looking back or
doing exercises like that um that I
notice the difference also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is learn from
different people how do you determine
who to interview or who's top 10 to put
together I have to learn something from
it so everybody that we've profiled I've
I've learned something from them and
this is where I think a lot of people
get messed up is that you only want to
learn from one kind of person where I
think the real unlocking comes when
you're willing to learn from people who
maybe you hate 98% of them but there's
one thing that they can still teach
you so you know I've got Steve Jobs up
on my wall and I've got my parents up on
my wall
wall I don't want to be a father like
Steve Jobs was a
father right he he wasn't a very good
one at least one that I don't aspire to
be like I want like my father
was but I don't want to be a Visionary
like my father was because he's not and
he's not an entrepreneur I want to be
Visionary like Steve Jobs was and so you
you your ultimate goal is not to be the
next anybody it's to pull different
things from different people to be the
best you right so um I have Kanye up on
my wall back there Kanye used to bother
me a lot in my my younger years like I
didn't like the bravado and the ego and
and the brashness and all that but
there's still a lot of that um there's a
lot you can learn from Kanye and so
everybody that I profile on the channel
is something that I have personally
learned something from that I've gotten
a takeaway and if we if I can't then we
don't publish there's a lot of people
that people have said hey you should do
this person and that person and this
person we have thousands and thousands
of requests from people to do I see them
in the comments
Lots I mean every day we get hundreds
every day it's it's wild I'm super
fortunate um but if I if we're
researching them and I can't I haven't
learned something from them then we
don't make the video rule number six is
surround yourself with positivity
whoever's more confident wins the reason
why that conversation goes your way is
because you believe in love more than
they believe in hate there you go as
strong as their belief in hate is or
negativity or whatever this as strong as
their belief is you just believe in love
and hope
more yes when you're around people who
believe in the thing more you gravitate
towards them so you will pull them they
will not pull you
down you will pull them up may not
happen right away it may be a process it
may take a week a month a year 10 years
but you will pull them up they won't
pull you down because whoever is more
confident in the thing wins that's how
you're pull them out rule number seven
is engage in physical activities and
terms of working out the first is 3
hours outside every day that's been a
new addition to my life it's been an
amazing new addition to my life uh I try
to work in chunks of 10:00 a.m. to noon
is focused work uh we're filming this
actually here at 10: a.m. eastern my
time so this is part of my focus work
block obviously I'm inside and then 12
to three is outdoor and I'm in Canada
Toronto Canada so so uh it's that's the
hottest point you know we don't get like
super crazy hot so I want to get vitamin
D we don't get as much here in Toronto
as other places so 12 to3 is outside and
I try to do work this is a big
adjustment for me is how do I do work
when I'm outside because I don't just
have three hours to go on walks every
day so I do all of my phone work and and
I've been especially uh happy with voice
to text so I I'll speak a lot of things
because typing on the phone is just too
slow compared to doing it here in my
office and so I'll do my DMs I'll do my
text messages I'll do my social media
I'll do uh calls with people anything
that I can do I'll do all my emails when
I'm walking and and it's all just me
talking into my phone and that's been a
huge GameChanger for me I'm used to
standing up so I'm on a champoline right
now I mean I'm I'm I'm bouncing on my
champoline uh that was a big game
changer for me earlier on in my career
but getting outside getting Sunshine um
getting the activity is is pretty low
impact right and it's just walking I'm
not coming back with like my heart
beating I'm not sweating like crazy but
it's it's shocking how just walking
every day can have a big impact on how
you feel uh on your health Etc so I
think most people just aren't getting
the Bare Basics of of activity and you
don't have to go and prepare to do a
triathlon or something like just walk
every day doesn't even have doesn't have
to be 3 hours that may be a little
extreme but like 20 minutes of walking
every day can change your life rule
number eight is be your biggest critic I
think you always need to be your biggest
critic okay you always need to be your
biggest critic and tell yourself that
you suck
and couple it with also being your
biggest fan and telling yourself that
you're the
best where I think a lot of people are
often their biggest critic but not their
biggest fan yeah right so so in the
moment where I feel great I tell myself
that this this sucks this is nothing I'm
just getting started this is this is
peanuts compared to what I'm capable of
and in the moments where I'm feeling low
I'm like I'm amazing look at all these
people that I've
helped right right okay I my Baseline is
usually very positive and optimistic and
and I live in I'm amazing so so then I I
force myself more on the that I suck and
this is nothing and I'm capable of way
more I need the force that I negativity
feels like the wrong word but force that
pressure on myself that this I'm just
starting I'm this is just a start this
is nothing I can do way more I need to
push harder but if you're living in a
world of negativity and and and
depression and then you need the
opposite you need to remind yourself of
how awesome you are rule number nine is
focus on what matters if you felt like
today you're going to wake up and you
weren't going to serve like you it
doesn't matter if you show up today you
go to work whatever nobody cares that's
the path down to depression anxiety
suicide all of that because you feel
like you don't matter to anybody yeah
but if you felt like today I was going
to do something that would matter to
somebody whether it's the world or one
person you're like I today is going to
mean something to somebody
else that's how you get to purpose and
happiness and fulfillment and R number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is keep going Denzel
Washington had this great line where
saying hey we're on a we're on a
mountain journey of growth like we're
climbing up a mountain
and the mountain is growth and every
time you take a step on the mountain you
reach back and help somebody else get to
where you're at right like you're never
done climbing you're never done climbing
so there's always more that you can can
continue to grow and get better and
learning because we feel like we have
there it is you know always always being
improving we're never and we feel like
an impostor because we don't know enough
because there always we're only look to
what we don't know but recognize that
you know if if Denzel or Oprah or
whoever is at like step a thousand and
you're only at step step 10 you think oh
my gosh I'm nothing compared to them
they're at step a thousand but you're at
step 10 right and where are most people
stuck right at the beginning yes so most
people in the world are at Step Zero
help them get to step one two nine you
can do that you can't get them to step
20 because you haven't gone there cool
don't stress about that get them to step
nine and as you go from 10 to 11 then
you help them get the step 10 right like
every time you learn a little bit you
then
and help people climb the mountain with
you I was curious if you like found
yourself taking on personality traits of
like recklessness like the you went way
far on the other side and like
discernment was starting to get grayed
the lines were starting to get blurred
has any of that ever crept into like I
know I don't want to live with regret so
I'm going to go all in on the other side
I don't think that happens okay you know
there's planners and doers and the
planners need to do more and the doers
need to plan more
but it's very rare that a planner just
becomes a doer and stops
planning yeah right say people who just
plan things for years and then they
still don't do anything and there people
who just take action but they're like
all over the place and tomorrow is a
different action the next is and there's
no plan or strategy and they end up just
running around in circles tons of action
but not moving anywhere you're just
running in a circle and so I think it's
it's uh I haven't really seen people
move from one category to the other but
whatever category you're in you need
more of that other thing people ask me
about humility it's like well you're
humble and all this stuff it's like okay
well I need more bravado I would be
doing my my mission more service if I
had a little more bravado and ego and
look at me and chest thumping it's taken
me a long time to come out of my shell
and even say yes to any interview like
I've done enough of these now but if
this was 10 years ago I would have said
no I would have said no Nicholas like or
what are your questions I need to know
everything you're going to ask me CU I'd
be afraid of letting you down or letting
your your show down and so I think
whatever those personality traits are
that you have I haven't seen people
completely move to the other side and if
anything you need more of that in your
life
so and I would think most people need
more of the let's not live with regret
because most people live with regret and
there's some few crazy people might have
a gene missing or something who like are
just insanely Reckless and don't care
and maybe they need a little more
caution and planning and strategy you
know so it's it's the self-awareness to
know what you need most yeah
self-awareness definitely helps
discipline is your missing ingredient
you've got the heart you've got the care
you've got the desire to serve you know
you could be doing more you want to do
it for the right reasons you're not just
here to make money you're here to have
an impact and the grow and do amazing
things you know you can do amazing
things what's missing discipline there's
just a lack of follow through it's the
constant start and stop and start and
stop and start and stop and for me
there's nothing
more not just frustrating but sad than
seeing somebody who's got so much talent
and so much potential and so much of a
heart and just seeing them not win
because they're not following through
because you're just not doing the
consistent enough work that you're
motivated and inspired and then and then
you're not anymore and nothing happens
and one of the only things that saved me
the only re one of the only reason why
I'm here making these videos and you're
watching and I've had any you know
success in social media is because I
just was disciplined that I just kept
making videos one of the things I love
sharing is my journey of YouTube because
I was not an overnight success
story uh every month almost I'll I'll
post to uh my socials of how I grew
month over month year over year here on
YouTube and in the first 5 years I had
7,000 subscribers or so so 5 years in 5
years in of making content 7,000
subscribers a lot of you are already
ahead of that a lot of you could get
there a lot faster than me you know how
do you keep going when you're not
getting traction when in year one you
have 100
subscribers I I just had the discipline
to keep making content to keep following
through and 12,000 videos later here we
are and and people can get there faster
you don't have to be as slow as me you
know I took I took a long time and I had
a lot of issues I was shy and insecure
and introverted and felt like you had to
be you know a type A personality to win
and all of these all of these limitting
Bel all sorts of issues and you can get
there a lot faster than me but it's
still requires the discipline to follow
through and do it and I really think
it's one of the only things that saved
me is to get really clear on what the
Habit is that you want to develop don't
pick 20 different habits that you would
want to do all at once this is where we
we struggle because we take on way too
much like okay that's it I'm done I'm
rolling up my sleeves it's time to
change my life I've had it I've had
enough I'm going to change everything
I'm going to work out and I'm going to
I'm going to eat well and I'm going to
make content I'm going to grow my
business I'm going to find a girlfriend
I'm going to like whatever the thing is
you come with 20 different habits that
you're going to do and guess what you do
it tomorrow maybe and then and then it
becomes too overwhelming too much too
much change all at once your life just
takes over and you end up back down in
the hole where you started does that
happen you tried to take on too much at
want what is the single most important
habit that you need to start to build
that if you look back in a year you
could say I'm so happy that I built this
one habit because it's helping you
accomplish your goals what is the most
important habit it it could be waking up
at a certain time it could be taking
care of your your mind it could be
taking care of your body it could be
putting in a certain amount of work on
your business it could be writing your
book it could be making a 100 videos
like what is the one habit that you want
to start to build that if that one thing
happened your entire life starts to
change it's the Cornerstone habit that
you start doing that because I guarantee
you listen if you start waking up at a
certain time or you start working out
you can pick any of them you start doing
one of those things that you're proud of
yourself for doing it other things start
to change in your life around you
because when you feel really proud of
yourself when you feel good about
yourself other things start to improve
too whatever you want to sell show me
the process of you doing it so if you
don't have an email list yet you can
even look at who's following you on
Instagram and message people and say hey
I I'm going to do a free coaching
session for people who wants 25 minutes
of my time for free to talk about about
coaching whatever issue you have you're
an entrepreneur whatever confidence
issue you're facing right now I will
Coach you for free but it's going to be
online okay those are two different
shows though the bis Dev show is we're
trying to build a relationship with a
potential clent and get them on the show
to tell their story but then inject a
little bit of what you do 25% of the
show is about you and confidence
coaching helping them the second show is
just a straightup coaching show where
they know they're coming on to be
coached but they may not be they may not
be an ideal client for you it's just
anybody who needs coach okay okay
because I need I I want to see that
you're a good coach because you can talk
and you can give me your Frameworks XYZ
and you can you can have all your
material you can but that makes you a
good
speaker how do I know if you're a good
coach right like Ted Williams was a
great baseball player but he wasn't a
great coach so you could be a great
speaker it doesn't mean you're a good
coach so how do I know if you're good
coach I need to see you coach so you
that's a that's a separate series on the
channel so now we're splitting it up
between the BISD show where we're trying
to get clients and a coaching show where
we're we don't care if their ideal
clients are not coming on We're just
trying to show coaching and and help
them of course and help them and then if
you have your website or you build out
your funnel that then becomes content so
when somebody lands on
hey hire Frankie to be your coach I can
see examples of what you do and how you
coach people how did you grow your
channel to millions of subscribers so
how I did it may not be the best way for
how you can do it right now uh early on
YouTube I started in 2009 and it was a
completely different game than it is now
where education was not the main thing I
made a six-minute video and people told
me it was too long and I was crazy and
nobody would watch a six-minute video
now YouTube is the number one place
people go to to learn the best teachers
are on YouTube you know they're not
Schools they're on YouTube so I would
start with you with well what's the main
thing that you actually want to sell I
mean I'm looking to help Real Estate
Investors buy their first property
there's three main shows that you can
launch the first show is what most
people think about which is the thought
leadership show you're making your eight
ways to launch your real estate career
or whatever eight ways to pick
properties eight ways to blank right
that means you're a good speaker it
doesn't mean that you're actually a good
coach or know how to actually help
somebody show number two is you coach
people so you have either ideal clients
or people getting their start in the
business and you come on and you coach
them and that's a lot easier of a show
to make because you just have to show up
it assumes you're a good coach right
talking to a camera by yourself in a
studio was the hardest thing to do at
the beginning when you're actually
helping somebody it's a lot easier and
then the third show which is the fastest
way to make Revenue money is a bizdev
show so you think of who are the people
who generate leads for you like who are
the referral sources for you other
investors other lenders Bankers property
managers or stuff like that so anybody
who refers business to you you start a
show and have those people and then
those kinds of people on your show
talking about real estate investing and
talking about real estate investing
where the goal isn't even to get a
million views on the video it's to build
the relationships because if a hundred
different people inside of the investing
World knew who you were who were all
dealing with your ideal clients now
you've built the seven eight figure
business just off of those relationships
try to pay attention to the micro
moments where you're
feeling like something's not great so we
had our first session on Instagram live
it was great you know your team messages
me for round two like yeah let's go
round two with Craig down right but if
you have somebody else if somebody on
your team who is bringing you down for
one day it's like huh okay that's
interesting if it happens the second day
a second week like maybe it's worth
talking and see what's going on if it
keeps happening like maybe that person
shouldn't be in your life yeah
and so it's constantly paying attention
to the things that give you energy and
take away it's really just about energy
management than anything else you
talking about balance like pay attention
to your energy and do more the things
and be around more of the people that
give you energy and my work gives me
energy I'm I'm leaving with more
energy with this interview than I came
in see right so like this didn't deplete
me it filled me up this is great thank
you absolutely and like we want to
strive to do more things that give us
energy as opposed to deplete and that
applies to your relationships your work
your sleep your your Fitness routine
your food all of it does it give you
more energy or does it take away the
reason why you're not following through
is because you're doing it alone when
you wake up and you feel like you are by
yourself you are all alone you have no
Community you're not collaborating
you're not doing this with anybody else
it's
just massively difficult to follow
through still possible absolutely but
this is the life of an entrepreneur this
is why so many great entrepreneurs don't
follow through and it breaks my heart
because you've Got Talent you've got a
desire to serve and to help and you know
you have a story that matters and you're
just not as consistent as you know you
could be and it's not that you suck it's
just that you're doing it alone this is
something I've struggled
with in terms of being a great resource
for people because I actually have a
very low community
need I think the journey that I went
through
is almost impossible to model because I
just woke up every day and I still made
videos and I still make content and I
did it by myself and it's not
prescriptive it's really difficult to do
it exactly the way that I did most
people need more Community than me I
still need it but I have a really low
maybe it's just introverted or or uh
what whatever but I just don't need it
as much as most people you probably need
more Community you probably are not
following through because you feel
isolated and alone and the great promise
of Entrepreneurship is freedom right
it's like you don't have to have a boss
you don't get to you don't have to have
employees that you hate or people on
your team who you hate you know you get
to pick everything you want but then to
go from having a job where you have
Community even if it even if you didn't
enjoy the work you were doing what you
got from the job if you've had one is
community that you had co-workers and
you had some people who you did like and
you had people to go to lunch with and
you you know you had just human
connection every day where as an
entrepreneur you don't have that nearly
as much or at all and so it's very
lonely and it's really hard to do great
work when when you're
lonely so what's the
solution like okay great yeah you just
tore my heart open Evan now what do I do
how do I fix it well first is just
recognizing that that that is a problem
you know first is recognizing that
there's nothing wrong with you there's
nothing wrong with you you're amazing
the only problem is you just don't have
anybody that you're collaborating with
that you're doing this by yourself so
the answer is we need to now go and find
other people to collaborate with so this
is where a lot of people get stuck at
the beginning say I love these people
and they're so good like want to help
and then you get you get pulled into
either helping them for free or doing
like super discounted
and you feel so fulfilling but it's like
you are not making money right so it's
it's just an order of sequencing so it's
not that you'll you're not able to help
those women in a deep way it's just not
now right because now is we need to
prioritize within our mission making
money yeah so that we can afford to quit
our job and then make more money so we
can afford to hire team to help us build
our brain so like I'm purpose first yes
you have to learn how to monetize right
right like number one is Mission purpose
and then somewhere in two to five has to
be making money if you're an
entrepreneur or you don't make money
right so that becomes now the
opportunity okay how do we take what you
do and be able to monetize it so why I'm
asking how can you connect it to your
current work is because the more we can
we can win off of just your magic which
is great which is like believe in the
gifts and then believe in the magic and
people will feel different being around
you and want to sign up on the spot
which is great okay and the more we can
lean in on any kind of credibility or
history or success stories or like
that's a hard part of the beginning of a
coaching journey is because you know if
you're not doing it full-time yet and
that's right it doesn't connect to the
job or work experience you've had it's
it's like it uh creates uh resistance to
want to hire you especially at higher
rates yes so that's what we're trying to
find is like inside of inside of your
story how can we pull out some elements
that give you more credibility so that
when you're talking to people uh they'll
just want to hire you on top of the
magic it's only a failure if you quit it
only counts as a failure if you stop if
you've got a big goal a big dream a big
ambition and you want to chase it down
and it doesn't work out on the first try
or the second try or the third try if
you keep going eventually you'll figure
it out this is the path of all
successful entrepreneurs like if you
keep going you keep putting one foot in
front of the other eventually it will
work out is why a lot of entrepreneurs
will preach patience because most people
quit too soon most people they
overestimate what they can get done in a
short amount of time and underestimate
what they can get done over a long
amount of time and they just quit too
soon you don't allow enough time for
momentum to actually take hold and so
it's only really a failure if you stop
people ask me about about my videos and
my YouTube channel and there's a couple
angles on this the first is how long
long it took me to get going if you look
at my uh my growth on my channel my
homepage you can see how long it took me
to get going it took 5 years and I still
had 7,000 subscribers or something like
that and the only thing that I had going
for me was that I just did not stop I I
was introverted and shy I still am I
didn't uh know how to make videos I was
very uncomfortable in front of the
camera I was completely embarrassed by
my own stuff first 3 50 videos I
couldn't watch back couldn't watch
myself back I was too critical of myself
too embarrassed that I was putting this
out um too hard on myself that I that I
wasn't good enough and that I wasn't
delivering value and just nitpicking
myself so many times on the videos that
I I just couldn't watch them back 350
videos public videos on my channel
before I was not just completely
embarrassed by myself and then 700
before I inspired myself like like oh
you know what I'm like that was pretty
I have one that I'm happy with after 700
public videos so most people just quit
too soon the only thing I had going for
me I didn't have the skills I didn't
have the personality I was not funny I
didn't have the editing capabilities I
didn't have the camera the technical
capabilities the only thing I had going
for me was that I kept going I had the
heart I wanted to serve and I just kept
going I just kept creating I just kept
making and now we're here you know
started from the bottom now we're here
that's now we're here but it took a long
time to get going and most people who
probably have
more natural
abilities more camera presence more
humor more fun uh they they could have
been way ahead of me not that it's a
competition but they could have had
success but they didn't because they
stopped they quit the AI tools are
incredible yeah so like if you're not
interested in AI and you're not applying
to your business and not F along you're
you're losing like you need everybody
needs to figure out AI in their business
100% it's getting better by Leaps and
Bounds like every week there's some new
tool there's some new thing you can do
it's crazy we've already uh accidentally
posted a video of me on my channel my
wife thought it was me and she posted it
to my Instagram and it wasn't me it
wasn't my video it wasn't my voice it
wasn't my script and my team was just
playing around with it and it to us as a
hey here's a demo and she thought it was
something that needed to be posted so
she posted
it what already and like it's only going
to get worse and crazier and more
authentic and more real like I could
watch and say that's not me but I
thought there's no way like people will
know but if it fooled my wife already
then it's gonna fool everybody right
what and was that software or it was
they put everything together from
different AIS it was different it was
the video Ai and then there's a script
AI I it was like GPT to write the video
like to write the script like use write
a script about belief in the voice of
Evan carmichel and then it pop something
up right um and then 11 labs to train
the audio to actually have it sound like
me and I've trained my voice right so
we've done the recordings and you have
all the samples so we've trained my
voice I don't know use it for yet but
I'm playing with it like you have to you
have to play with it so train my voice
the video one I don't remember which
we're playing with on a bunch of video
tools remember which video tool we use
to make it happen um but yeah like it it
we posted
it and wow then I had to go back and say
oh this is this is AI Evan you
know but it's only better but this is
where nfts come in this is where yeah
why it's so valuable because that's that
still requires a lot of it's It's GPT
plus 11 Labs plus whatever video tool
you know then to make it into an
Instagram video like it's a lot of it's
a lot of mess to figure all that out
that's all going to go away just like
nfts it's hard to set up a wallet and
figure out ethereum and buy and get like
it's it's it's hard but that's gon to
all go away that's going to be the
default right it's going to be easy in
the future to make that happen most
entrepreneurs aren't patient enough most
entrepreneurs end up losing their
business they end up shutting down
because they think it's going to happen
in a couple months or even 6 months or a
year and really it's going to take them
four years 5 years before they H their
Mark they don't have enough patience
they don't allow enough time for
momentum to build up and they quit and
they end up going back to a crappy job
that they hate and maybe never ever take
a shot at get an entrepreneurship
because they feel it's not for them or
really they missed out you missed out on
your destiny you missed on creating
something amazing because you just
didn't have enough patience now I
believe in patience in the macro I
believe in patience and knowing it's
going to take a long time I also think
impatience can serve you greatly but
that's in the micro that's in the daily
the impatience of did I do my best today
did I do my best today can I do better
can I drive more can I drive harder and
knowing that even if I give my best
every single day it's still going to
take time it's still going to take a
number of years for something to happen
I want it to happen as soon as possible
I'm going to drive and be impatient as
crazy to get it going but I know it's
going to take time too it's embracing
both that's when you start to win I look
at my my YouTube my Instagram my social
media strategy YouTube 7,000 subscribers
four years ago 1.2 million subscribers
now four years by making videos every
day every day and I'm impatient as
anything because I want it to be amazing
I want to make every video better than
the last and looking for all the hacks
and SEO and thumbnail strategies and
title strategies and all of the stuff
that we're supposed to do right I'm on
top of it and I know that it's going to
take me 4 years to get there I know it's
going to take me while to get to my next
2 million 5 million 10 million
I look at Instagram follow me on my
Instagram Journey I'm starting from
nothing you can see how to build it up
from zero I had 8,000 followers many of
you already have more followers than I
do on Instagram but I'm going to win I'm
going to pass people I'm going to get
mine because I'm going to make daily
consistent content three to four times a
day for four years I'm going to be
impatient as anything and that the post
today has to be amazing has to be
something that I want to show my
grandkids right that's the intent every
time I create anything I want my
grandkids to watch this video I want my
grandkids to watch the next Instagram
thing that I put up it's the best that I
can come up with in the moment and I
know it's going to take me 4 years maybe
3 years maybe 2 years but it's not going
to take me 2
months I realized it's going to take
working hard and working smart together
always how are you able to overcome
those barriers that were kind of those
limiting beliefs that are maybe holding
you back from becoming the thought
leader inspirational person that you
wanted to be that you are now the
starting point for me really was I
always focus on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't most of the time
we're focused on who we're not yet well
why don't I have I've got what three and
a half million subscribers now why isn't
at five or like 50 or 100 or a billion
you know it's like it's always who are
we not and so at the beginning we really
struggled to get going because 25 people
watched your video and you feel like a
total failure especially if you've had
success in a different field if you had
all the success in real estate investing
and then you make a YouTube video and 25
people watch it it's like that's rough
yeah feels like you you if you've
already tasted success it's really hard
to start at the beginning of something
new we feel like I've got information
I've got good know I should I should be
doing better than this I just always
focused though on who I was serving and
who I wasn't when I started on YouTube
IID already sold my company I already
had my first exit I was already in the
Venture Capital game as well so we
already had some success I was just
doing it to try to give back and serve
and help and so if 25 people saw the
video I'm like hey that's 25 people who
saw the video that's 25 people for one
person I might be alive changing video
and I just always focused on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't and and
it grew to the point where they started
recommending and referring and I
understood the algorithm a little bit
better and YouTube caught up to being an
educational platform um but if you can
focus on that that hey I did 25 today
and I did 28 tomorrow and I did 35 the
next day it's like this the growth curve
starts to take off for you what is your
superpower what is my superpower yeah
believeing me people yeah so I
thought yeah you know I think whatever
the thing is that um you know what's my
biggest Kryptonite believeing in
myself you know like the thing the thing
that you want to give to the world is
also the thing that you need the most
too so now people say well you're the
believe guy how do you not believe in
yourself well I believe in myself to get
here to do everything that I've done
it's it's the next
step the next level of EV carich is on
the other side of even more belief and
as I learn and improve and grow and
figure out some new strategies I'm going
to then share it with my audience as
well if you want to guaranteed way to
move into action apply the 595 rule
spend 5% of your time planning and 95%
of your time doing 5% planning 95% doing
most people are afraid to apply the 595
rule because you're afraid that you'll
take the wrong action that you'll make a
mistake that it won't be perfect but
here's what's going to happen while you
are sitting there planning your perfect
next move someone with less Talent with
less skills than you will win with a
Half Baked idea because they applied the
595 Rule and just got started and then
don't think about it just go off and do
it stop planning that's the plan the
plan is done stop planning now do I am
not feeling so hot this morning don't
know if it's just the lingering effects
of the uh variant or what but um just
super low energy a little nauseous a
little dizzy but uh still getting my
still getting my sun still getting my
walk still going to do my fast and still
make as much progress as we can some
days you can do more than others just
make sure on the days that are less than
others that you're still getting
something done that you don't mail it in
if you don't give up that you don't quit
what's the quote sometimes you can fly
sometimes you can
take the car sometimes you can run
crawl just keep moving forward keep
moving forward when life gets hard when
you have every reason in the
world to turn back what do you do you
press forward how you are like
connecting with your followers on a
level um that is adding value to them
but is allowing them to continue to
consume your content one you have to
love it MH like I love connecting with
the community okay so there's a lot of
people who who don't love it and you
don't have to do it right so I remember
I was in New York and was meeting a
really big name author you know New York
Times Bell Etc and I was in town said
hey let's go grab breakfast so we grab
breakfast together and he said well what
are you doing for the rest of the day
he's like I'm going to have lunch with
another fan who said he like became a
millionaire after watching my content
and then we're going to do an afternoon
meet up at a Starbucks with you know my
fans in New York and we're just going to
chill the Starbucks and ask questions I
don't care about seeing New York I just
care about meeting the people and he
said that sounds exhausting like oh what
are you going to do it's like I'm going
to go back to my room and write and he's
had tons of success as a writer right so
it's not that one way is better than the
other it's just that I I love doing it
and so it's tapping into like if that
where you get your energy from of the
audience that you have and people
listening to you watching you Etc then
that's where the thing needs to be
birthed not from uh this is a good
strategy so I guess I should do it right
so inside of that I do things like that
where I do meetups in cities when I
travel uh even here inviting you back
it's like you message me he's like hey
what are you doing on Tuesday you want
to come by and do something you know for
Content too and every day I'll do
Instagram questions if you see my
stories I always put a question and then
at the end of the night my evening
routine no matter how tired I am I'm
still like responding to questions I'll
do like 10
questions you're responding yourself
yeah it's me like when I'm helping
people I try to do it where there's
scalability to it as well okay
so you know the the people who are here
today that I'm helping they're helping
but it's also content so other people
can learn from it hopefully in in your
story right when I'm doing Instagram Q&A
it's on my story so people can leave a
question I'll answer it for
everybody okay right um I still do a lot
of one-on ones in the DMS as well but
that there's just not enough time in the
day to hit everyone even the questions
that come in every day don't have time
yeah to do everybody but it's more of a
heart thing where it's like it I need
that as part of my nightly routine to
stay connected to the
work because otherwise it becomes why am
I doing this stuff you know the numbers
start to blur and not mean much right
you know you had a million or two
million or whatever it's like okay I
don't know what that means but
somebody's saying your video changed my
life you saying you know I watch your
videos for eight years every day to
learn from somebody new that that's why
I do what I do I need to feel connected
to who I'm serving or helping okay and
in doing that then it makes me want to
show up more cuz if you're just making
videos in your office or you're just
recording a song in a studio and you
can't connect to like who it's going to
actually help at least for me it's not
as powerful that negative voice inside
your head that's telling you that you
suck and you can't do it that's not your
voice that's not actually your voice
that's not you telling yourself that you
suck that voice was planted there that
voice was put there by somebody else in
your life and probably early on growing
up telling you that you can't do
something you were not born you didn't
come out of the womb and say I suck I
can't do anything no you're playing
you're experimenting you're finding Joy
you're laughing you're you're doing it
and then along the way people tell you
that you can't do it that you should
stop that you should quit that that it's
not going to work out that you can't do
it and we've been so conditioned around
that that we take it on and we think
it's our
voice when you come up with an idea
right just Workshop there this you come
up with an idea I'm going to I'm going
to go I'm going to write a book I'm
going to start a YouTube channel I'm
going to launch this business I'm going
to whatever you come up with your your
bucket list your your dream life your
vision board you come with a list of
ideas things that you think that you
want to do things that you feel
confident that you'd love to create for
yourself right okay what happens the
next day the next day it's not even
telling our friends you know I think we
we blame our friends and say well we
tell our friends and they're going to be
negative and and they they they crap on
our idea and so we don't do it well
before that happens we crap on our own
ideas right you look at that list the
next day and say I can't do that who who
who was I yesterday this crazy person
that I used to be yesterday who thought
I could do that it's ourselves telling
ourselves that we suck but the problem
is we've taken on that voice and we
think that it's us that's not your voice
that is not your voice telling you that
you suck that is somebody else's voice
that was planted in your head that has
been conditioned to be there that we're
so used to being there that we have
taken on as our voice it has become your
identity but it was not your voice it
was put there it was a seed that was
planted that has been grown over time
and you need to rip that weed out that
is not your voice you do not think that
you
suck it's other people with low
expectations who hate their own lives
who at some point went and tried
something that did not work out for
their life and now nobody around them
can have success because it makes them
look and feel bad and so they spend
their time ripping other people down and
apart that's who planted that weed in
your head that might hit pretty hard I
hope it does cuz when that H when if you
can
actually digest that what ends up
happening is you think oh who whose
voice is that who whose voice is in my
head head and that's great awareness to
know that it's not your voice and then
to identify whose voice it is who told
you these things who made you feel this
way growing up and if you think about
who that person is if you can actually
picture somebody oh that was Uncle Joe
or oh that was my grade three teacher oh
or that was my you know the bully at
school whoever that person was now think
about okay it's that person's voice not
you that's already incredibly liberating
but then too do you want to live that
person's life like think about that
person probably they're not living a
great life they're not hitting their
potential they're not even happy with
what they're doing if somebody's
spending their day tearing other people
down what kind of painful life does that
person have to have when they go home
you don't want their life if you don't
want their life then you definitely
don't want their voice in your head
anymore hopefully that creates an aha
moment for you that starts to actually
shift things because
we've been so conditioned to listen to
that voice that we don't recognize that
we actually have a choice to rip it out
and start to listen to our own voice how
long were you thinking about inviting me
on before you invited me
on it's a great question I've been
mulling on it for a long time this is
our mutual connection I interviewed
Kevin paulm okay who is from The Next
Level University and you've been on
their show twice okay so since I got in
contact with him and he spoke so highly
of you
that's how long so 6 months seven months
I mean I don't think I even looked at
your Channel or what you're about or
whatever just your message and I decided
so I would have said yes seven months
ago right exactly right it's about
taking action jumping right into it so
but so you never know like this is this
is the thing and whether it's as big as
I might regret this in the future if I
don't if I don't say yes or ask or or
whatever it's also just the mulling
things over now again kudos to you for
then deciding to do it cuz a lot of of
people then never do it they never reach
out they never ask they never start that
business they never write the book they
never whatever the thing is that they
want to do a lot of people s months
later have already told themselves why
they can't do that thing and so you then
you know congratulations like you did it
and here we are and I might have said no
or I might have ignored you or said I
hate anybody named Nicholas like you
never know you never know when you send
something what the reaction is going to
be and you're just getting started in
all of this right yes
the opportunity here
is there's the big long-term opportunity
of you could help whether it's everybody
whether it's women whether it's women of
color or whatever that says a lot of
people in in even just North America who
need that yeah the immediate opportunity
is figuring out okay how do we how do we
replace our salary correct because the
the women on the train may not be able
to afford you as a coach right so this
is where a lot of people get stuck at
the beginning say I love these people
and they're so good and like want to
help and then you get you get pulled
into either helping them for free or
doing a like super discounted rate yeah
and you feel so fulfilling but it's like
you are not making money right so it's
it's just an order of sequencing so it's
not that you'll you're not able to help
those women in a deep way it's just not
now right because now is we need to
prioritize within our mission making
money yeah so that we can afford to quit
our job and then make more money so we
can afford to hire team to help us build
our brain so like I'm purpose first yes
you have to learn how to monetize right
right like number one is Mission purpose
and then somewhere in two to five has to
be making money right if you're an
entrepreneur or you don't make money the
environment makes such a huge difference
for who you are and your daily habits
and what you believe about yourself and
the environment is not just the people
who are around you although that
definitely helps you know if you've got
negative friends or family around you
you want to eliminate them completely or
spend a lot less time with them because
it's really really really hard to have a
beautiful plant grow when it's just you
know toxic waste being poured on top of
them doable but really really really
difficult and so changing that can
really help and one of the best ways I
found to do it is
content it's content it it's why I make
so much content for these channels that
hopefully you wake up today and there's
a piece of content there waiting for you
whether it's me or showcasing somebody
else across all my channels we're making
multiple pieces of content every single
day to try to hit it in the right way
maybe today's message with the right
voice is the one that makes a difference
for you and if you can
shift the amount of entertainment you're
doing or just uh shutting off the world
some of the content that you consume
just helps you shut off the world and
Escape versus educational content that
helps you learn improve get better and
solve the problem right entertainment is
let's forget about the problem and just
laugh at something else education is
let's learn to actually fix the problem
that is happening in our life right I
want to lean in on that a lot more it
doesn't mean that entertainment doesn't
exist in your life it's not only
education but if you can shift the
needle towards education to be around
the people who inspire you even if
you've never met them it can really move
the needle for your your inner dialogue
and your self-confidence I think
comparison to other people is fantastic
I think most people just do it wrong I
think most people just do it wrong you
look at somebody else you see their life
you see what they're doing you see their
business you see their success you see
how old they are is one of the common
question people ask well how old are you
well typically it's because they want to
they want to judge their own progress
against
yours the comparison can be great but
you have to use it as a kick forward
instead of a kick down most people will
kick themselves down they realize that
you haven't you realize you haven't done
much you realize that you're not where
you want to be you realize all these
other people have done it with maybe
less resources than you at an earlier
age than you and you feel like it's over
and you can't do it that's a kick down
it's a comparison it's a kick down and
that's what most people do and that's
why there's so much advice out there
from people saying don't compare
yourself to others because when we do it
we typically kick ourselves down that's
the wrong way to do it the comparison to
other people comes from knowing what's
possible and being inspired to want to
go off and do it you know I just came
back from a trip with um my beach gang
and it's some bigname people it's
Brendan bashard and Mel Robbins and uh
Lewis house and J Shetty and you know
all these all these big people who've
done big
things and we sit around the
table and we share and we help and it's
our own Mastermind it's not a paid thing
it's where they go and and we all share
and as they're talking as they're
sharing what they're up to and what
they're working towards
words I'm thinking that's what's
possible that's what I could do if I
wanted to that's what that's how they're
doing their marketing okay if I could do
this and maybe they're three years ahead
of me but by learning their strategies I
can get there in 6
months the comparison pushes you forward
runners run faster when there's somebody
next to them businesses innovate faster
when there's competition
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday is not enough of a push
forward that's the problem comparing
yourself to who you were yesterday is is
a great it's great for
self-love but it's not enough of a
push so I encourage you to start
thinking about an audit for yourself
right
now if you're really low if there's no
self-love if you don't feel like
anything is possible that's where you
look back and you look at the progress
that's when you look back and say where
was I 5 years ago where was I 10 years
ago look at how much you've grown and
learned and improved and how much in a
better situation you are compared to
where you used to be even if it's not
financially just mindset just mentally
just the kind of person you are how you
treat people you probably grown if
you're watching this channel it means
you're into personal growth
self-development so whether it's from my
videos or somebody else's content you've
been learning and growing over the past
5 years you've grown a lot you're not
the same person you used to be you're a
lot more proud of yourself than who you
used to be and whenever you're feeling
low on yourself that's when you look
back and track the progress that's when
you look back and see who you used to be
and how much you've grown and improved
and gotten better and that can start to
fill you up
again but when you're ready for
growth when you're ready for ambition
when you're ready for the next level I
think the comparison is fantastic I
think to know that something is possible
it's the whole Roger banister foring at
mile nobody thought it was possible then
Roger banister did it and now
everybody's doing it not everybody but a
lot of people did it why because they
were comparing themselves to him because
they know now that it's
possible and so when you see somebody
else do it when you see somebody else
making amazing things you don't have to
default to say I suck because they're
doing it and I'm not that's a kick down
you can
choose to use it as inspiration to say
that's what's possible and if she can do
it if he can do it then so can I and use
that as the push to get you to the next
level at our beach
gang last year I got challenged a couple
times I got challenged by Brendan I got
challenged by Russell Brunson I got
challenged by a whole bunch of people
and and I got challenged without people
even talking to me sometimes just by
them sharing their
story I look at that and say I want to
do
that
not in the way that I suck and I can't
do it but no in a year I want to be
there in 2 years I want to be there in 5
years I want to be there I want to be
there I want to be there I look at young
Les Brown I think is's the greatest
speaker of all time I don't look at him
and
say he's so much better than me he's got
this natural gift I suck I'm never going
to do it I look at him and I say I want
to be that good that's what's possible
it's an inspiration to move forward so
how do you make it tactical there's a
couple things that I think would be
helpful for you
one look at some people who you respect
inside your industry or outside your
industry it's just something that you
respect about them maybe it's me maybe
it's Jordan Peterson maybe it's Oprah
who who are the people that you look up
to in respect what are the things so two
what are the things about them then that
you want to get better at if you respect
somebody it's because they're they're
ahead of you at something that you want
to be good at maybe it's in their
business maybe it's in their speaking
maybe it's in their relationships
they've done something or they're living
a way that is ahead of
you so what is that thing too what is
that thing what is the thing that they
have that you are aspiring to get better
at there's no one person who is the
ideal Mentor you don't want to be me you
don't want to be Jordan Peterson you
don't want to be
Oprah they have parts of their I have
parts of my life that you don't want the
whole point is to take different pieces
from different people to make the best
you you want to I for me I want to be a
Visionary like Steve Jobs that's why
he's on my wall and I want to be a
father like my father was that's why
he's on my wall I don't want to be a
father like Steve Jobs was and I don't
want to be a Visionary like my
dad because they're not so you're taking
different people and different things
from them to help you become the best
you so one is you're making a list of
all the people that you look up to that
you respect that there's something about
them that you you gravitate towards two
you find that specific thing I want to I
Want to Have Courage like this person I
want to have love like this person I
want to be a husband or or a wife like
this person right I want to be a mother
or father like this person that they're
the ideal to to shoot towards that
improve you to make you want to strive
to get better and then three you dive
into their story you dive into their
content you dive into their videos their
books their podcast their biographies
you dive into them on a consistent basis
watching One video is not enough it's a
consistent basis to help you start to
think like that somebody asked me
yesterday why do you read so many books
at a time I read uh seven to 10 books at
a time I never really thought about why
I do it it just seemed to work for me
but as I dissect it I love micro doing
on books I love micro doing on content
cuz think of what happens when you read
a book so one of the books I'm reading
right now is jett's Think Like a monk so
when you're reading jett's book it it
forces you to start thinking like a monk
it forces you to have more presence and
more gratitude and more mindfulness and
if you're going to read some hardcore
the other B another book in bring is 75
hard from Andy frisella which is in your
face hardcore punching you in the
stomach you know yelling at you let's
go two two totally different Vibes I
like both I don't want to be J shett I
don't want to be an
forella but I like the mindfulness and
present of of J shett and I like the
aggressiveness and push of any forella
and in in that combination is Evan
carmichel so why I read seven to 10
books at a time is because the micro
doing of the books when you're reading a
book if I only read J shed's book i'
become very mindful very grateful very
present and then I put the book down and
I pick up a different book and then what
what you start to do is
lose the train of thought you lose the
thing that you learned from Jay unless
you're picking up another J chett book
but he's only got one out right
now so instead instead of going hardcore
and just reading one book I like having
J shett once a week I like having Andy
faella once a week I like in the videos
that I make to have different people we
have Jordan Peterson once a month and
Elon Musk once a month and Oprah once a
month because diving deep on one person
can be great but what happens on the
ongoing I'm much more concerned about
the ongoing than I am about the what's
happening intense at the
moment because the ongoing is how you
win if you want to have success in
anything going going to the gym and
working out for 4 hours is not going to
do much for you but if you go to the gym
every day for half an hour you start to
see
results so all of that a bunch of stores
in there but the main concept is I think
comparison is fantastic you just have to
use it smartly when you look at somebody
else understand that you don't want
their entire life you don't want their
entire life but there's something about
them that they're better than you at and
use that as inspiration for you to get
better instead of you telling yourself
that you suck and you can't do it
comparison will push you forward
comparison will help help you get the
life that you want as long as you're
kicking yourself forward not
down to see 10 more amazing rules for me
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there the environment
is the thing that's keeping you small it
takes a giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't